voilà la fibre de canne que l'on appelle
plus communément de la bagasse c'est le
nouveau carburant de la sucrerie du
galion plutôt pour employer le terme
scientifique exact le comburant à ce
stade de la production cette fibre a été
pressé huit fois pour en extraire le
maximum de jus et par cette juillot elle
remonte à l' usine d'électricité dans le
vieux mas où elle sera brûlée pour
fabriquer de la vapeur
cette vapeur va redescendre par d'autres
tuyaux et elle fera tourner les turbines
de la sucrerie ou plutôt elle fait déjà
tourner les turbines
après deux mois d'essais les bons
réglages semble avoir été trouvé entre
les deux unités
c'est en tout cas ce que nous assure le
directeur et le président du galion
l'objectif c'était bien de rencontrer la
nouvelle configuration dans laquelle
nous sommes et qui fonctionne et
d'ailleurs hier lusine a quand même
envoyé 1000 tonnes de cannes
ce qui est exceptionnel dont on sait que
ça tourne
c'est que les choses tournent ils
tombent sur une journée c'est une ombre
donc nous allons envoyer environ 18000
même un peu plus de 18 mille tonnes dont
les choses avancent de manière positive
les premiers essais ont donc débuté le 6
avril dernier il a donc fallu quelques
semaines pour synchroniser les deux
unités
et si depuis le début de la campagne 18
mille tonnes de cannes ont été broyés
les représentants de la sucrerie table
sur un tonnage d'environ 45 mille tonnes
pour la fin de la campagne le 15 juillet
je précise quand même que nous partions
de loin nous partions d'une chaudière
qui est de mise hors service
il fallait trouver une solution
d'urgence pour que la campagne 2010 8 l
ue ce n'était pas gagné énormément de
choses ont été faites en très peu de
temps
très peu de temps
donc ce pari nous l'avons gagnée couplé
à albi yuma le galion peut en principe
voyez jusqu'à 600 mille tonnes de cannes
met notre production n'est pas
suffisante pour atteindre ce tonnage
prochain rendez vous pour la sucrerie mi
juillet pour tirer un nouveau bilan
définitif de cette campagne